le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
certaines personnes consacrent leur vie
aux autres surmonte des épreuves tracent
leur chemin avec courage et
détermination pour récompenser les
parcours de vie remarquable de ces
réunionnais ou réunionnaise le
département a créé en 2006 le prix du
mérite
jean-paul bavol est un des personnages
connus du milieu musical et théâtral
locale mais c'est pour son action
sociale et son investissement pour le
quartier du bernica que le saint polois
fait partie des lauréats cette année
[Musique]
là on va faire un tour dans le jardin on
va sortir dans le temps d'aujourd'hui
pourront retrouver dans le temps de lire
c'est un voyage qui nous plonge aux
racines de la culture créole au camp
marron dans les hauts de saint paul jean
paul bavol il son association ont recréé
le jardin longtemps de nos grands
parents
moi je constatais que la jeunesse ne
connais plus trop grand chose surtout ce
qui avant est on en train de payer d'un
peu tout notre richesse et ensuite les
fruits et les légumes lontan nous va
dire que c'est un héritage de nos
anciens quand il manger beaucoup de
fruits de légumes lontan
il était en pleine forme il avait une
santé de taureaux en dix ans
y amène un produit
cette limite
toutes les plantes ils ont une histoire
une vertu tout tout tout et de là on a
les liens de patates cochon ces graines
de patates cochon qu'on appelle le matin
aux patates de chine c'est une patate
qui est médicinales c'est bon pour
brûlures d'estomac les budgétaire et
pour rafraîchir tout ce qui est dedans
sans savoir jean-paul le partage avec
les jeunes du voisinage en quête de
repères
l'association fait appel à eux pour
l'entretien du jardin car à travers ses
projets jean paul veut avant tout
développer son quartier et recréer des
liens entre les générations
depuis je suis passionnée de la culture
locale de tout ça est déjà tout
passionné a aidé à entrer des camps
cette idée la mairie dans ma tête je
pense que comme d'ibanda c'est une
piqûre de peut-être d'un ancien qui a
voulu que je mets ça devant en avant
mais pas pour moi partager le partage
c'est d'ailleurs le thème du jour au
camp marron
aujourd'hui l'association met à
l'honneur les personnes âgées
elle leur propose entre autres des
ateliers bien-être et tous les habitants
du quartier sont les bienvenus cette
journée de solidarité de chant de
partage
une fois par mois nous on essaye de
faire de perdrix mouvement pour que il
l'a toujours ils coupent pas le pont des
fois c'est des personnes handicapées qui
viennent c'est ce moment là cette joie
de partage et d'échangé
cette chaleur humaine pour tout ça parce
qu'on sera tous un jour dit
[Musique]
la celtic ugine la cour quand les gens
ils viennent il ya toujours la
participation des voisinages chacun
amène son petit chacun et puis on compé
client partage en demandant la paix
tranquille monde va se promit dit un bon
coq au vin bon cari haricots blancs avec
doc de chou bon appétit donné mon coeur
et c'est de bon coeur également que le
saint polois a été reçue à la villa du
département fin août aux côtés de 19
autres lauréats
il a reçu le prix départemental du
mérite une récompense qui valorise les
parcours d'hommes et femmes investis
dans leur domaine ce sont des gens qui
au fond ne savent pas qu'ils sont
extraordinaires parce qu'ils mènent leur
vie au quotidien de manière toute simple
avec passion ce qu'ils se réveillent à 4
heures du matin ce qui s'occupe des
autres ceux qui se disent un jour hors
d'âge suis porteuse d'un handicap mais
moi je veux devenir championne malgré
tout et comment réussir et il y en a
tout autour de nous des gens qui vous
donne de l'énergie des réunionnais de
l'ombre et qui pour un soir de vienne
pour eux mêmes et se découvrent eux
mêmes c'est nous qui sommes honorés
c'est nous qui sommes fiers de
rencontrer au quotidien des gens aussi
dynamique formidable et ce soir on avait
envie de leur dire
[Musique]
retour au bernica l'après midi se
poursuite avec une session de devinettes
dans le car courants d'air du jardin
donc toi de monterrey est et chantée par
attal dans le cas en courant d'air
maintenant que nous avons un petit cric
et crac et on tape est tellement petit
lapointe la place pour mettre la mémoire
dedans
l'ariel ac n'a rien qu'un place points
aux yeux et guînes naples était bien
pour l'avoir
les sourires les rires
la convivialité c'est la raison d'être
de jean-paul bavol mot l'ombre il était
coupé la dent donc tant que dieu me le
permettra je le ferais je j'aime bien et
des entrées des faits participer habib
les gens et surtout apporter la joie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le prix départemental du mérite a été
créé en 2006 il valorise les parcours de
vie de personnes souvent dans l'ombre
qui sont des modèles de courage et de
volonté
jean-paul bavol fait partie des lauréats
2010 est il a créé l'association du
centre d'insertion sportives et
culturelles du bernica parmi leurs
actions il y à la création d'un jardin
longtemps pour transmettre les savoirs
et valeur des anciens pour découvrir le
jardin et l'association rendez vous au
camp des marrons au bernica et pour plus
d'information sur le prix départemental
du mérite et ses lauréats
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site
www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]